hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday hey hey hey
May 8th
2023. what's going on how are ya uh geez
how you doing oh Billy raspy voice
just did two shows in Las Vegas at the
park MGM
used to be known as the uh the Monte
Carlo
which I confused with the Bellagio
you know because they looked very
similar until Park MGM bought it and
they they put the green out light on it
maybe that's why they did that maybe
because the MGM is green maybe Green's
their colors I don't know what but all I
know is I did two shows out there and I
want to thank everybody that came out
um had an amazing time and
um it was an unbelievable show too I
brought Nate Craig out who's got a
special coming out very soon with all
things comedy
um
and then we had uh uh Erica Rhodes was
on a two who uh [__] killed me all
weekend was absolutely uh hilarious if
you don't know about her you definitely
should
um just an amazing comedian and we had a
great time first time I ever brought her
on the road and she was she was
definitely fun hang
um
it was just a great time it's had a
great time you know
the first day I went down and uh the
[__] elliptical stunk you know oh oh
my God I can't even I can't [__]
believe how out of shape I am I'm like
so like in in shape out of shape
big guy they had a little Jazz Gretch
kit
backstage
for me to mess around on and there was a
mirror to the side of me dude and I sat
down and when I looked over it was like
it was like all my muscle just turned to
fat and just went like right
I mean I I just my back and my front
were just like it's like oh my I look
like a [__] salesman
you know
like that's what it looked when I
remember when this when I worked in the
warehouse when the suits you know at the
company picnic
all of a sudden would be out there in
like a [__] t-shirt and you'd be like
Jesus Christ waited that [__] 40
pounds come from
so uh yeah I really let myself go here
man I got to get I'm you know
so I'm pretty uh but I did good though
you know the whole weekend
the room you know has all the [__]
snacks in it all of that [__] stayed
away from all of that the only thing I
took was I had a uh
I had some peanuts
it's some douche right now go too much
sodium the sodium you're gonna retain
water shut up I'm not a fitness model
okay it was the best [__] Choice
other than the the M M's Three Musketeer
what else do they have they already
[__] candy body could possibly want
um stayed away from all of it
for the first time ever because I
usually I'm like I ain't [__] with
any of that [__] and then Kenny will be
like do you want me to take it out of
the room I'm like no it's fine it's fine
I can [__] handle it you know and
then I'm [__]
you know it's funny I used to do that
when I was a kid
I used to get up early in the morning
and I would sneak like a chocolate chip
cookie because no one was around and uh
I remember getting caught by my dad
we literally had a cookie jar this is
how old I am we actually it wasn't in
like a package you had a jar of cookies
my mother probably made them so it was a
cookie jar and there was chocolate chip
cookies in them in there and like you
know
I don't know how parents are now like
you know they just give their kids
[__] whatever I'm gonna do that old
man thing we're like you know back when
I was a kid you couldn't get sweet but
they but my parents you know
my dad was a dentist so he's like yeah
you're not eating that [__]
like the only time we had soda was when
we went to Papa Gino's to get pizza then
you were allowed to have a Coke but you
couldn't have a Coke but we all had
paper Roots every once in a while we
would go up to the uh to the corner
store up there and uh buy some football
cards but you know it's funny I could
never finish a soda I just always felt
like
I was drinking like I don't know what
like it was
your belly would get all distended I
could never finish it when I was younger
um
but anyway
yeah I woke up one morning and I um one
of the many different places I lived at
as a kid
I think we're on the North Shore at that
point like
hopped up on the counter
you know literally had to do like a
muscle up I was so small you know
got up there maybe I brought a stool
over and I literally had my hand in the
cookie jar made like a breezeway
and my dad had left I didn't even know
he had left but he forgot something and
he had come back in the garage was on
the other side of the Breezeway and he
just tapped on the glass with his keys
as my hand was literally in the cookie
jar just like the expression
hand in the cookie jar
um
so I've always been like that so I'm
trying to
trying to finish that
part of my life
just I'm just like well I turned 55 on
June 10th and I am not [__] having
any sugar
um
until then right and then what and then
what Bill you're gonna go back to show
I'm not doing any heroin
until you know I'm really starting to
realize the amount of [__] that people
are addicted to like I actually think
that the new addiction
and I'm actually guilty of this
is like social media and the internet
and allowing it to uh it does something
to your brain
or whatever
like you know it's [__] weird like if
I see a video and it's like nine minutes
long I'm like I don't I don't have nine
minutes
you know but then I will sit there and
watch like 4 000 [__]
one minute clips for the next five hours
or whatever I know the math doesn't work
out but you know what I mean
but I'm not going to sit there and
commit to nine minutes although I did
watch an amazing documentary wait stick
on the stay on the subject bill
um I actually think that like
um
social media and all that stuff it's
starting to make people like mentally
ill
and it's creating a new race of people
I'm going to call them the instagramers
because
you know like when you look at a picture
on Instagram and you clearly know you're
like that that photo has been [__]
with
right
like this like
I don't know a filter or they elongated
the body or like
you know Nip Tuck here or there or the
person's had plastic surgery now I'm
actually seeing people
clusters of people they seem to hang out
together
like races do you know white people over
here black people over there you know we
are right
now you have the instagramers and you
see them they they [__]
there's shiny
they have all top label stuff and they
don't they almost you're looking at them
you know they're human wait are the
robots here you're looking at like they
they kind of
they don't look like any people I've
ever seen before
their faces aren't sweaty they're shiny
and it's like younger people too so I
think they're
they're getting like uh
I don't know I think the way the guys
are tattooing their face I think a lot
of the women are Botox in their face
when they're young I have no [__]
idea but I'm looking at these people and
going like
I just couldn't put my finger on I go
what is going on
what what what these like I just keep
seeing they pop up more and more and
more I think the robot's already here or
some really
um good looking in a different way
aliens
have begun you know living amongst us I
don't know what it I don't know what it
is
everything's like e Celeron bien salaga
uh that [__] M store store begins
with m
M you know what's that one I don't
[__] know you know all that Designer
label [__] and you're just looking at
them like you got like that's like a you
got like five grand worth of [__] on
above your waist
like I don't you know I don't know
um but anyway and then you got those
types of people
who are trying to look kardashian-esque
and then you have the people that you
can tell you can see it on their face
that they argue politics all the time on
the internet they have they they have
like the weight of the world on their
face
and um
and then this bizarre sort of idea that
they that they know how to change things
or that everything would be perfect
if we all just did what they wanted to
do I'm kind of noticing
you know
as the widget salesman has faded away
getting onto airplanes
the instagramers
in the politicos whatever they are
they look like uh
I don't know
like you can't just be having like I did
it so I did it to my buddy today
like you know I watch the podcast and
somebody just said something so [__]
stupid
I I didn't I I didn't know what to say
about it it was some
I don't want to get into it because I
don't like start a [__] war with like
another podcast but it was just like
essentially
I don't know how to talk around it but
it was just one of those things where
it's just like how could you be so
[__] ignorant
like you know that thing that people do
where they act like history
Begins the second something bad happens
to them
and they don't try to see well how did
we how did we come up to this point like
how the [__] did we get here
you know what I mean it was like Trump
when Trump [__] got in office and I
remember seeing this person on TV going
oh this was uh white people wanted to
take the country back they wanted to
take the country back with this guy and
it's just like
well there's way more white people
than you know
they could have easily just voted
against Barack twice and he would have
lost so that's not what it was
it was I think it was 2008 when the
bankers [__] everybody again yet again
and they got away with it and then we
just had career politicians Barack Obama
career politician Hillary Clinton career
politician and then this guy comes in
like [__] you know Hacksaw Jim Duggan
right
saying he's going to clean everything up
even though he's part of the [__]
problem
that was one of the most amazing things
I saw oh the rich guy who doesn't pay
taxes is going to help me out okay
this should be oh I'm gonna drain the
swamp I'm [__] neck-deeping so
um
anyway I don't know what the [__] I'm
going with this [__] but like uh like
people they they they act like
you know
I don't know why might I just get off
the subject because I'm gonna end up
saying what it is and I just don't need
to create any more [__] drama in my
life
um speaking of drama
the goddamn [__]
Florida [__] Panthers won again I
just watched him win in overtime I
watched the game they are [__]
relentless
they look they're like Jason from Friday
the third like their goalies should be
wearing a [__] Jason mask remember
those old horror movies in the 80s with
like the victims running away in the in
the in the the [__] Jason guy is just
walking briskly and somehow catches up
with them and they're always tripping
over [__] logs that's what the
Florida Panthers are they've won six
[__] games in a row
remember when Toronto won their first
playoff series since uh
I don't know what we've been riding
horses to get to work some of us still
do Bill all right fair enough
I love horses it's a lot of things I
love but like I don't know anything
about them I do love horses
um anyway
you know they make you want to work out
I don't get the legs though I just don't
understand how they don't tip over a lot
of those big [__] things with the
little legs moose
mooses right horses giraffes
just don't understand it like why they
have such little [__] likes
I can imagine if they had like more like
linebacker [__] legs a weight lifted
legs
just kicking the [__] out of lions get
me all right there Fred well the Florida
Panthers
six games in a row so anyways when the
Toronto Maple Leafs won their first
round of the playoffs they were chanting
we want Boston we want Boston you know
because they wanted Revenge maybe or
maybe they knew I mean they know hockey
better than we do up there right
maybe they knew like that we don't want
to [__] play the Panthers
these guys are Relentless oh God some of
the [__] play though man I swear to
God I have never seen like so few like
they don't hit each other anymore
so I'm too old to know the names all
right my kids are too [__] young for
me to know the names okay so this guy
number 13. lucky number 13 on the
Panthers
you know stretch pass whatever they call
it
at the panther at the uh Maple Leafs
Blue Line
catches it realizes you know he's not
going to go in the zone he circles back
lets everybody kind of catch up and then
he kind of you know goes through like
right through
two maple leaves one of them was
covering another guy but he was sort of
like one and a half guys were there to
stop him he goes right through him
nobody even didn't even put a glove on
him
push him touch him nothing nothing
he brings it down half wall and he
[__] shoots it around behind the
goaltender goaltender goes from from his
left post to the right post
and number 13 keep skating the [__]
I'm not gonna say the number because I
don't like [__] [__] on people as I
[__] up all the time but the [__]
Maple Leafs guy sort of half-ass
so to stop skating
and 13 goes right past them
they basically did like a give and go
Panthers shoots it back to him he's
behind the net the [__]
Maple Leafs goalie looks to the left is
13's coming around the right by the time
he realizes ah [__] he right through the
[__] legs over
over with like five Maple Leaves just
standing around like what the [__] just
happened
I know the feeling I watched three
straight games of that
I'm really fascinated with this [__]
team
I respected him when they played us but
I [__] hated him because they were
beating us now I'm just fat I'm like I
gotta watch this team like because
because this is if they [__] go all
the way this is gonna be epic
so I've been watching that series and
I've been watching the uh Edmonton
Oilers uh
Vegas Knights uh series which has been
great and I swear to God I was like I'm
just for fun I'm gonna put 100 on the
[__] was it Vegas right
the [__] I'm not gonna gamble have a
little bit of fun you know
pie taking the festivities there right
so um
I'm like I put 100 bucks on Edmonton I
think they're gonna [__] kill them
I think they're gonna [__] kill them
and I went downstairs it's [__]
hilarious Park MGM and this woman for
bet MGM is standing there trying to
solicit me to go in there I want to be
like so listen to me I've been [__]
promoting you guys for like I don't know
how many years on my goddamn pot you
don't know who I am I'm the face of this
[__] company lady no I didn't think
that I just thought it was funny
um
and I never got around to putting the
BET down I should have done it though
they came out gave the Vegas Knights the
old right there Fred
to the tune of four [__] goals
in the first period
that Edmonton Oiler playoff uh Power
Play is just [__] insane
you know I just realized all I've done
is talked about sports up until this
point I think I have
you know hey it's that time of year
ladies
you know
I mean you should be happy I'm talking
about sports ladies the way [__] ESPN
is putting all your non-ratings getting
[__] Sports on Jesus Christ
the [__] are they gonna put on next
I've never seen so many goddamn women's
sports this is amazing like
they haven't even earned the right to be
on TV as far as like ratings and there's
like a crowd and all that like that new
[__] game of tennis it's like Ping
Pong had a baby with tennis
whatever the [__] that pickle it's a new
[__] game I'm like that's [__]
that looks like tennis for little people
even that shit's on TV but I know that
is a [__] craze amongst young men and
women
right
that's the new rollerblading back in the
day you wanted to get laid you went out
you bought a pair of rollerblades you
skated around you learned a couple of
Tricks right
you went out there in your milk white
freckly thighs skating around Central
Park
open some chick would [__] be like oh
you know
I always wanted to [__] day to
translucent [__] orange person
um now it's that pickle [__] but I'm
wondering Now ladies okay you bitched
you bitched your way onto ESPN you [__]
moaned and complained you're way under
ESPN
all right
you did it congratulations now women you
got to sit down and watch this [__] so
they can start making money
oh my God they got to be taking a bath
on this [__]
[Laughter]
it really is amazing when women complain
like how much [__] gets done it's just
fine just they they the way they
complain there's like no way to shut
them up until you just give them what
they want
you know you got to put [__] like
cross you gotta put there's a field
hockey women's field hockey on ESPN not
two not three not even not ESPN one you
got to put on the first one the original
Channel
it's like uh nobody's watching your
sport yeah it [__] sucks all right
all right let's put it on Jesus Christ
anything to shut them up
anyway I'll be honest with you I'm
hoping that one of them takes off
make some money you don't mean women's
tennis does great right
I would say I don't know why they're so
[__] dumb
okay
they they should [__] it's women's
volleyball
women's [__] volleyball
you got to put that on there because men
will watch it and men watch sports
I think what ESPN is trying to do right
now is trying to would be like trying to
get guys to watch
like if they put like the uh The Real
Housewives if they did a male version of
that like we're like we're gonna sit
around
like we already have that
it's called the pregame and post game
show before and after a sporting event
[Laughter]
I'm just [__] with you ladies I know
but it's really going to be up to you
I ran a break in your [__] ovaries
over here all right you guys should stop
watching that stupid dumbass reality
[__]
all right and help ESPN out before they
lose their goddamn shirts showing all
your [__] Sports all right there's
your ladies there's your strong powerful
women these poor [__] women athletes
out there blowing out their [__] ACLS
the least you can do is turn on the
goddamn TV and watch it I will tell you
this I like women's softball
you know
I just love those [__] pictures
however you learn how to throw like that
Whoever thought underhanding pitching
could come in that [__] fast
that's like how you throw as a little
boy like under here you go here you go
and then somehow they turn that into
like I don't know how fast they throw it
all I know is I couldn't catch up with
it now with my old goddamn body I went
to the doctor listen to this [__]
uh I don't have rotator cuff issues I
have bursitis
and a little bit of arthritis to go with
my tinnitus I got all the Isis people
bursitis arthritis and tinnitus touch it
touch
you know
a truffle oil portion
of arthritis he says my shoulders are
fine as long as I don't act like an
idiot
for the final third of my life
[Laughter]
anyway uh
so we're gonna start some treatment on
that [__] and uh
I don't know see if I can [__] get it
going what does she really do is just
admit to the fact
that
um going to be 55 years old and I need I
need to start lifting the pink weights
that's what I need to do I need to go
lightweight you know a lot of stretching
[__]
sprinkling cranberries and bran on this
[__] whatever the [__] it is I'm
supposed to do
so
um had a bunch of people come out to my
show out there when I was in uh Vegas
and
ran into an old friend old friend of
mine
uh you might know him from uh the
Storage Wars
Kenny Crossley
some of you just probably know him from
that show but back in the day he was the
doorman at the Laugh Factory from like
1995 to like around 2000 whatever right
and when I first came out to LA
in like 96 when I was like 28 was when
28 years old
I thought I was old then I was a [__]
kid and I met him and he was just we all
knew him as Kenny the doorman
and all these Boston Comics all moved
out there at the same time for my
generation and I'd gone to New York and
then got an acting gig out there so then
I was out there
and um that dude was like
like
for me was like the one ray of light
when I was out in LA because I got my
[__] ass I mean La is it's funny
where people sit there and they oh you
know it's a [__] plastic town I buy
everybody's so phony and La La Land and
all that this this [__] town is
brutal
is [__] I found this town harder than
New York
you know how come anyone write a song
about [__] Los Angeles maybe they
have
it's always just said [__] didn't the
eagles do something about it Hotel
California was that about it I'd have no
idea
but like they're always writing songs
that's like blowing New York City if I
can wake up in a city
I found New York to be
maybe because I'm from the East Coast I
just found it way easier
you know it just was uh
I don't know I can't even I don't mean I
don't even I spent so long since I've
lived there I don't even remember why
but when I was in New York
it felt all right and it like made sense
and even like in Show Business which
makes no sense it made more sense back
there but when I came out here I was
like this is just [__]
like I don't even know which direction
to walk in out here like it was just
this open expanse of space
is all of these [__] people and there
was like uh
you know very few Avenues to get in
because I have to be honestly like I see
now like
I tell you these kids today these
comedians like the opportunity that they
the control that they have over their
own destiny is [__] amazing
and watching like I'm literally watching
Comics blowing up now
without the industry
you know they can just like they can
film themselves post clips and do all of
this stuff and get this momentum going
like they're just these self-sustained
units like I think in the future you're
going to see the no manager no agent
ever
no stand-up special comedian ever just
clips
and everybody's gonna know oh he or she
is and they're going to make their
zillion dollars on all they need is like
an entertainment lawyer or something
like that
um you still need somebody to talk for
you to to
book your money they'll probably figure
you know they'll get some AI [__] to do
that
um anyways the writers strike is going
on out here I've been
[__] busy here and going on the road
so I hope Billy's gotta walk the picket
line
you know I'm in the writer's Guild
I've written a lot of [__] jokes over
the years I should go down there one two
three four just give us the [__]
money you [__]
it's unbelievable the way I gotta be
honest I'm so glad I'm not just a writer
because the way that they treat him it's
like this town is literally nothing
without him
you know unless you want a bunch of
reality show [__] but now they got like
that I guess they got this AI [__] where
they'll be like
you know write me a play like William
Shakespeare
hahaha
ah
you guys ever watch idiocracy like it's
it's getting scary how [__] accurate
that is becoming
because I feel like I'm starting to be
shaped like those people
wasn't that the movie where they
couldn't get up anymore that was the oh
that was a that was a Pixar movie
combining them
but uh I did see a clip the other day
that said
you know when they were designing the
clothes of the future
that they uh they forgot to design the
shoes and they just found the dumbest
shoes they could ever find they're like
don't worry these things will never take
off and they were Crocs
ah Jesus anyway so
I got to sit after my second show and
talk
with Kenny Crossley AKA Kenny the
doorman for my generation of comics and
we just sat and talked
for the better part of the hour a better
part of an hour just going through the
old days man it was [__] awesome so
um anyway Let's uh
let's do some of the reads here oh I've
been I came home at [__]
you know hung out with my kids and all
that and then I had to go work out
um
because uh I'm gradually being shaped
like a pear
and uh
I drove my new truck man I [__] love
that thing I [__] love that thing God
damn it I love that thing I have no need
for it whatsoever but God damn it I love
that [__] thing all right let's do a
little bit of a little bit of reeds here
um
oh look who it is everybody indochino
looking sharp all wedding season long
shouldn't be expensive with a custom
fitted suit from indochino you'll create
Priceless Memories without costing a
fortune customize every detail on your
shirt your suit shirt dinner jacket and
more in a range of colors from a
traditional black or gray to burgundy or
Olive to a classic Hemsworth Navy they
got a nice green too
I actually saw one of their stores the
other day I was going to go in and get
the suit because uh
I want to go as uh
De Niro's character in casino
Ace rothsey why Ace was his real name
right Sam rusting
um every every suit is made to your
exact measurement and you can customize
every detail create a suit that fits you
and your style perfectly with options
for Fabrics lapel shape custom Monograms
statement Linings and more they also
have tuxedo starting at 579.
why would why rent when you could buy a
custom tux you can re-wear for years to
come it'll also keep you in shape
you know instead of just renting a new
one every time a little bigger a little
bigger a little bigger right then all of
a sudden you [__] put on a tuxedo you
look like a bouncer in a strip club in
the 80s
sorry I just remember I [__] went to
Club super sex
that's the name of it Club super sex on
Saint Catherine Street in Montreal
Montreal Canadiens versus the North
Stars and I went up there with some
buddies of mine working in a warehouse
and we [__] went up to that club and
I still remember this guy
it was working the doors just [__]
1980s roids
okay you think the fake tits were big
back then you should have seen the
biceps this guy [__] was like
he was like the size of a refrigerator
and you just and he had a
double-breasted
suit over
that guy was a [__] house
um but even on indochino could get him a
double-breasted for [__] 579
indochino also offers completely
completely custom fitted shirts casual
wear and more get a superior wardrobe
personalized to your style and taste
without the luxury price tag uh they're
always adding New pieces and options so
you can stay on Trend and in style
explore they're relaxed yet refined
approach to Spring suits with their new
spring Fabrics
RSVP knowing you've got the perfect look
all wedding season long from indochino
go to indochino.com and use the code
burb urr to get 10 off any purchase of
399 or more that's
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o.com promo code Burr
hey do you guys think that game pickle
is going to eat into uh the NFL
NBA NHL MLB
when was the last time one of those four
got toppled
because a hundred years ago uh maybe a
little more than 100 years ago the two
biggest Sports were boxing and horse
racing
and then baseball and then Along came a
guy named Babe Ruth
and an owner who wanted to produce a
Broadway play uh ZIP recruit up
everybody look who it is Jose
when I say zip you say recruiter uh
whether you're standing starting a new
business or growing one if you wanted to
be successful you need the most talented
people on your team right the Lakers use
zip recruiter to get all their free
agents every [__] year that's where
it zip
comes in and right now you can try for
free at ziprecruiter.com
why would you let see yes
help you hire for you why should you let
them help you hire for your business
well Jesus Christ they're powerful
matching technology finds high quality
candidates for a wide range of roles got
your eye on one or two people who'd be
perfect for your job zip
yeah let you send them a personal invite
so they're probably more likely to apply
a personal invite isn't that nice to do
it also offers attention grabbing labels
that speak to job flexibility like
remote training provided
urgent and more to help you to help
yours stand out let zip recruiter fill
all your roles with the right candidates
four to five who post on zip
get a quality candidate within the first
day see for yourself go to this
exclusive web address uh to try it out
zip
recruiter.com slash Burr again that's
ziprecruiter.com
zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire
um
where are we going here
you know what's funny is women's sports
finally gets the TV coverage
it would be funny if they just stay low
in the ratings and then they also called
that sexist they said that the rating
system was sexist and then they bitched
their way into like actually being
called the number one sport in the
country
um
I would enjoy that all right Harvard
Harvard Jesus Christ you're on the wrong
podcast you're bringing this up uh
Harvard
h-a-r-v-a-r-d Harvard bill was listening
to anything better podcast and heard you
talk about how nice it must be nice nice
it must say
you're from Harvard
not from Harvard you went to Harvard in
a disagreement
um this person said I graduated from
Harvard eight years ago and can tell you
100 percent that there are a lot of
morons who go to Harvard ah I love
hearing that
did you ever just say to yourself when
you were there like I am at the [__]
College
in the United States everybody knows it
is
even if they're smarter people elsewhere
[__] Harvard where did you go to
college Harvard
it's [__] unreal
listen
even as a [__] Meathead I can't hate
on that place you got that Roman
Coliseum
you know when you're five foot eight
offensive guard blocks for your [__]
five foot six quarterback
um they have the ability anyway they
have the ability to understand
where am I I [__] up there are a lot
of mornings who go to Harvard they have
the ability to understand really complex
systems of math and science but when it
comes to anything outside of those those
fields they're just idiots
well yeah I mean something's going to
suffer if you're
if you got the Beautiful Mind there
right like Matt Damon did in that movie
you know you're not gonna have any
social skills although he did right
he was pretty good picking up the chicks
whatever it was a [__] movie I still
like that movie but
um
yeah well I mean that they're too busy
trying to figure out how much liquid is
in a cylinder aren't they
anyway Harvard Business School is a
great prep for life if you're going to
work for companies that have the same
agenda as as Harvard which boils down to
this Harvard graduates who run large
companies and hold High government
positions are always looking for more
Harvard grads to come to do to come do
things the way they are doing them oh
wow so it's like a ivy league Mafia I've
heard about this
I've heard about this well that'll you
know
I went to Emerson College people out
here at Emerson hook each other up
why can't you guys carve up the [__]
world
well us Emerson people uh write skits
anyway
if it makes money and doesn't disturb
their status quo it has a chance
all right let's just stop doing my jokes
here and just read this so you guys can
hear okay Harvard graduates who run
large companies and hold High government
positions are always looking for more
Harvard grads to come do things the way
they are doing them
um having a new or original idea is not
praised unless it's unless it's made
money if it makes money and doesn't
disturb their status quo it has a chance
my wife went to a quote regular
four-year school and is light years
ahead of my colleagues in the same field
getting to Harvard is harder than
graduating well that's kind of what I
was saying but like I wish you a
you kind of elaborated more on what how
in what way is your is your wife light
years ahead uh never and I mean never
think someone from Harvard knows more
than you about anything just because
they went there I know I mean I never
really thought that but I did respect it
I mean it's not you're not smart you had
to get in there unless your dad went
there and you're some dope
I get that if you're what do they call
that you're a
lineage
what is that I'm a legacy
I'm a [__] I don't know
I don't know what it is Ivy League
schools are the greatest farce in
education
Jesus Christ dude
did you have any fun at this [__]
school I mean you Achilles just like I
said I believe in Santa Claus you're
like ah
it's just some fat plumber in a robe
um it's like saying
well they were on SNL so they must be
funnier than me
what do you mean
like like me saying that or you saying
that I'm a stand-up comedian so I think
I can hold my own
because we're both doing the same thing
but I you know
before I was a comedian or for a long
time I thought everyone SNL was funnier
than me I'm not saying they're not still
funny than me but what are you what are
you talking about what are you [__]
on SNL for
anyway no SNL is an institution and it
helps to be on it but you are absolutely
funnier than a lot of people whose names
have been forgotten from that show no
shade to SNL as you throw it under the
bus just needed an example all right um
all right well I think what you're
saying you can kind of say that about a
lot of [__]
but um
you know I mean I'm not going to debate
you you went there
but I I would say this can you have like
a little more Pride that you went there
just so
you know
a guy like me can still hold it up high
in my fantasy of what it is I just look
at the buildings and all of that [__] I
just remember just seeing us like
this is like something I'm never going
to experience like this is just
[__] I wish I tried in high school you
know
like that with like if I tried it would
have turned it around anymore it's
amazing I mean I think
whatever I mean someone's got to run the
country why not be you guys
and as far as what you're saying about
how Harvard people think people in
Showbiz think the same way when it comes
to money on on the other side of the
desk it's like we're not going to try
some new [__] and all and risk all of
our [__] jobs we're just gonna keep
like whatever's in right now that's why
they keep making these superhero movies
because they're [__] working people
keep going to see them they will make
those for the rest of time for the rest
of time until people stop going to see
them like remember remember they just
came making all those vampire and
werewolf movies for a while
in the 80s they had all those action
movies there's always like something
that
is a big hit and then they just keep
ripping it off ripping it off ripping it
off until they just you know kind of
dies on the vine
um
that is pretty fascinating to me though
though but I will say they're still yet
even though all the stuff you said about
Harvard still must have been great
I think that's
he's like my top schools that if I
studied I wish I I like I went to
just and I'm just basing all of these on
the campuses
all right
all right Harvard
um
the other all the [__] Ivy League
schools
they always look amazing yet sort of
creepy
I did a few of those schools I just
always remembered like
it's just so so you know you walk in you
just feel people being like ew
I don't know what is he doing here
um uh University of North Carolina
beautiful campus
uh
uh it's another one UCLA
uh Stanford
it's another one then there's some that
I went to I'm actually fans of the
football program but you know but I'm
not into the school like University of
Michigan Jesus Christ
it's a [__] City
all these college gigs I did and I can't
even remember the ones that I liked
Georgetown
I am a [__] elitist snob listen to me
just rolling through these here
uh UMass Amherst no kidding
um
yeah I don't know
wow I was going way back in the [__]
bin for those trying to remember those
I think I did more College gigs
more nights of college gigs than I
actually was in college
and granted I commuted
I see those [__] things all the
goddamn time
get like a college agent they just route
you through the whole my college agent
was out in the Midwest and just [__]
send you through all of that [__] out
there
all of that land and it was always like
in the wintertime and all the crops were
cut down it was [__] freezing cold
out man
um
it's just always ended up in Nebraska
Kansas
Iowa and South Dakota
Minnesota oh Jesus
[__] brutal
brutal
that little Dre you know
that quadrant right there
Wisconsin always gave me hope you know
Illinois wasn't bad
as long as you were near Chicago
you know at least you knew that I I'm
definitely a city guy
[__] going out to those goddamn
places I was I think it was on the 29th
I can still remember the roads some
[__] road
35 is the one that goes up from
Dallas all the way up I want to say to
Minneapolis this is the one just west of
that and the numbers go down
right starts with the five
and they're all odd numbered if they go
north south and even if they go east
west that's how I'd figure out if I you
know back in the day when you had a
[__] map rather than Google Maps
[Music]
um
all right I'm babbling here uh old NBA
old NBA big men
oh I was talking about this how I I just
missed the the two seven Footers
battling
you know
down below the the Elijah ones
Kareem's Robert Parish all of those
[__] guys man it was great Bob Lanier
um
Moses Malone uh
Moses would kill you
um anyway old NBA big men now all those
guys are just taking [__] three
pointers which it's amazing that they
can hit the shot but it's just like
everybody's like a [__] point guard
now
um anyway hey there Billy double dribble
I was listening to your latest Thursday
podcast when you were talking about how
you missed watching big men battle down
in the post
I am right there with you I miss it too
it drives me up the [__] wall when I
see a seven footer choosing to shoot a
fade away shot as opposed to going
through the defender's chest sadly this
is where the game is at is already at
yeah I mean it's not going to change
either so I mean this is their game they
like it that way and now they're into
this game called pickle when I was a kid
pickle was uh you were doing like a
rundown like in baseball
um is it called pickle I don't even know
pickle paddle paddle pickle uh those
nerds who have never learned
how to use their dominant hand say
there's a higher probability of success
when you spread the floor with nobody in
the lane oh is that why they do it all
right
a big thing to look
at is the upcoming NBA draft to see how
far down Zach Eddy from Purdue gets
picked 20 years ago a seven foot four
inch 300 plus pound Center who is mobile
and can knock down free throws would
easily have been a lottery pick now he
won't go in the first round
I miss the old days boohoo thanks and
zip
go [__] yourself
I like that ending
um
yeah it's like I don't know
it's just it is it is a different game I
um
I've kind of tapped out from the NBA I
tried watching the Celtics and that type
of stuff I just I just find hockey so
much more exciting
um
but any but even that game has like
changed like there's people just skating
around with the puck
nobody getting [__] up the days of the
Scott Stevens coming in and just [__]
ending your career with the shoulder to
your [__] head as you I mean that
obviously they had to get rid of that in
the game but like
um
there's not a lot of checks or anything
like that just everybody is like a
a [__] beast
stick Handler you know
um so it's a lot faster game it is
exciting
but I gotta say like I don't know
I guess it's easy for me to sit here and
not risk CTE and say I wish it was still
more physical but in basketball yeah I I
do kind of miss that
um
I like that guy and then I do like the
Knicks so I was watching some of the
Knicks uh
and I was saying to uh Paul verzi you
know Nick's his team and I was talking
to him about that guy quickly
you know I'm like there's no way his
nickname isn't the adverb
it has to be right and he just laughed
he goes no no one said that
um
anyway I missed the seven Footers
battling I don't think it's going to
come back so I'm just happy that I saw
it and uh
I don't know it's just I think it's this
is just um I'm just sort of realizing
this is just a part of getting old
um evil nerds in Africa holy [__] all
right everyone I think everybody come I
guess I hit some uh
hit some sensitive points you guys are
all [__] like
clapping back as the kids say
um
oh I heard somebody else say an
expression wrong one of my favorite
[__] things ever
uh I saw a clip on the internet where
this guy said he's not the brightest
bulb to ever come down the pipe
[Laughter]
that's my favorite thing in the world
they're becoming like expressions
because I you know why I love it because
I do that all the time I [__] them up
I'll get in the middle of them and I
can't [__] remember them
um like verzie calls me out on it all
the time
I remember [__] Patrice O'Neal rest
his soul I was trying to teach him that
expression uh
oh those who can do those who can't
teach
I said that to him he was talking about
like
I forget probably a comedian teaching a
comedy class when that was like a new
thing
and he goes you that motherfucker's
sitting there you know teaching comedy I
was like well you know those who can do
those who can't teach and he was like
what I go you never heard that
he was like no I said yeah those who can
do those who can't teach it's expression
and then he was trying to say it
it kept going those who can do
no wait I go no those who can do and he
just kept going those who can do he
wouldn't he wouldn't pause
and I was driving him home and I was
just laughing my [__] ass off and he
couldn't he could he couldn't get it and
then he find those who can do those who
can't teach
um yeah so I heard somebody it's
actually somebody I'm a fan of
said he's not the brightest bulb to come
down the pipe
and it actually it's it's the original
expression is to come down the pike and
then people just started saying the pipe
and it and else it used to be I believe
he's not the brightest bulb or he's not
the brightest bulb on the Christmas tree
I think that was the first one he's not
I think it was initially he's not the
brightest bulb on the Christmas tree and
then it just became too long to say so
he's not the brightest bulb you don't
need to go you know when in Rome you
don't need to [__] keep going right
unless you're talking to Ron Burgundy
right
so anyway
I got a kick out of that I'm starting to
write write them down do you guys want
to start sending me those in if you hear
your parents or hear me or somebody just
saying an expression wrong and then we
can actually find out how you're
supposed to say it
so God forbid you guys won't sound as
dumb as I do
um all right evil nerds and Africa
all right uh hey Bill I'm an African who
has lived in the U.S since I was 12.
I've been listening to your comedy since
I was 15.
um
uh the World Views are appreciated look
at me huh
Oh Billy back in the class actually has
a decent world view according to one
person who's allegedly from Africa
I mean who knows I mean I'm just taking
everything you guys write at face value
that it's true right all right he's an
African who has lived in the U.S since
he was 12. he's been listening to
broadcast since uh he's 15. all right
I've been reading a lot about African
struggle to maintain autonomous control
of its continent
oh boy
Jesus Christ what are we going to do
with that one
every great animals going to be in the
zoo we're going to wipe out all the
[__] forests
I don't understand I just don't you know
whatever I'm not gonna think that big
because it gets depressing
um you're always talking about evil
nerds so I wanted to share some
something horrible I've been reading
about and hope to shed more light on in
my future professional career as a
filmmaker
oh I mean yeah I mean I'm gonna watch
your films if you're gonna be talking
about evil nerds in Africa uh The Gates
Foundation
has been supplying vaccines to African
countries for almost 30 years now in
some cases it has been successful and
immune
immunizing against things like malaria
but one vaccines they've been providing
for 20 plus years was removed from North
America all the way back in the 90s
because it was killing more people than
it helped
oh my God is that true it is illegal to
distribute this vaccine in America when
the foundation tried to sell it to
Denmark their officials asked to see the
studies but the Gates Foundation was not
able to provide any information or proof
that it did any good
so basically they had invested in this
vaccine
they found out it didn't [__] work
and then they had too much money in it
and they knew that it killed people and
they said all right [__] it will go to
Denmark now right now all the people
that didn't take the vaccine for covet
are like
um ignoring the fact that these same
people have also defeated every [__]
plague since the beginning of time for
some reason
you know you're only as good as your
last vaccine
scientists are like the NFL quarterbacks
or relief pitchers you only as good as
your last [__] safe then scientists
and doctors from Denmark went to Africa
to study the effects of the vaccine on a
controlled population and found that it
was causing more harm than good and let
me guess these people had no idea they
were being tested on the government of
Denmark tried to alert the World Health
Organization that more children have
died
that would have been exposed to the
disease in the first place they're still
Distributing this vaccine and still
causing unnatural effects why would you
sell something that already is
classified as a health risk
yeah well I mean you know what's funny
is the same people that won't take the
vaccine are eating the bread in this
country which is complete [__] poison
our food is poison everything is [__]
poison at this point because all anybody
gives a [__] about
is money
so the only thing you can Bank on is
they don't want to kill all of us
because then they'd have to dig their
own ditches right
so
I don't know
it's [__] chaos
why anyways because no one really okay
why would you sell something that
already is classified as a health risk
because no one really cares about Africa
they just do it for the money well buddy
I got news for you they do that here in
this country with all kinds of stuff
um anyway the person says I don't like
these nerds even more I hate the idea
that someone is considered intelligence
based on their ability to build a
computer and create a company
yeah I mean
uh
what you know you know what's amazing
why don't empathetic people ever get
into positions of power it's [__]
bizarre
it's almost as if they get weeded out so
the person goes on to say you often call
yourself a [__] but you're not you're
just coming to conclusions the same way
quote smart people do
I don't quite understand that last
sentence but if you think I'm smart I
appreciate it
um all right well make that [__]
documentary
I love documentaries I wish I could I
wish I
let me see if I can find
this documentary
um
somebody made the interview
these people that went and fought over
in the Gulf War in the very beginning
like 20 years ago and where they are now
and how they feel on it about it and
everything
um
it was absolutely riveting it was it was
put together great there was no politics
in it it just it's it's it really was
what documentaries used to be
before the Michael Moore generation
where Michael Moore didn't make
documentaries as much as he made like
op-ed pieces this was like clearly his
opinion
you know like
um I finally figured it out when when he
like totally just ball washed Canada
well they leave their doors unlocked and
whoopie doopy there's no [__]
problems up here
um
anyway uh here's one here uh Mr first
Porsche
hey there you Bigfoot buffoon
you making fun of my truck you son of a
[__] that's fighting words here in
America
um parentheses it's okay I'm also size
12. oh foot size
oh okay
um I thought you're making fun of my
truck there was a famous Ford truck in
the 1980s called Bigfoot I don't know if
you guys are into monster trucks
um it's okay I'm also size 12. I'll let
you borrow my Jordans clearly you know
what race I am now the kind that wears
lotion well I mean everybody wears
Jordans but once you said lotion that
kind of narrowed it down anyways last
week you talked about how anxious it'd
be to have a sports car in a city
um
let me tell you it is I recently bought
my first car a Porsche 718s now I gotta
look this [__] thing up because I'm
not good with the Porsches I know the
911 Targa that's the one I want I want a
new one in that 1970s orange I don't
even think they make it like that
anymore all right Porsche
what is it a Porsche
718 s
all right
no not spider s you [__] stop trying to
[__] write for me
oh [__]
that's a good looking car
what color did you get it in
[__] you white you know they always have
to have those testosterone names
before the colors
I don't know it was my [__] throat is
more than so goddamn dry being out there
in the desert
um
all right let me tell you this I
recently bought my first car it's a
Porsche 718 s
718s
718s I don't know how to say it and
every time someone attempts to park near
it I have to stick my eye through my
blinds
oh my God last week I was so nervous of
this lady in an old car reversing
quickly in front of me
I ran out of the house and guided them
with my hands like I was on the tarmac
marshalling a plane
laughs
[Applause]
all right right off the bat I
respect the car that you bought and how
much you love cars that's amazing
slash terrifying
you know
you get a [__] park next to these
other people that just could give a [__]
so it gets me from point A to point B
you know I don't give a [__] I get no
attention from Girls the only attention
I get is from Old Men Who occasionally
come to my window and go you did it kid
uh what year is your 718 s
last week I got an oil change 800 bucks
luckily I had a warranty or else
disservicing would have cost me five
grand
would you go to the dealership
Additionally the car is so low I have to
get therapy for my knees from getting in
and my back from the quote sporty
suspension and yet I love it it's a
beauty sports cars are one of the few
things Where Art and Science
are in perfect unison
wow
I never thought of it like that I'm
going to read that again sports cars are
the one one of the few things Where Art
and Science are in perfect Unison you
sir are able to refined
gentlemen
fixing you drinking a little [__] uh
espresso
up in the mountains after you did a
drive you know like one of those [__]
movies we got one of those sweaters
you know they always have like those
[__] sweaters on
the guy with the wavy hair
some blonde chick with them
you know she also has a big sweater and
no [__] pants on whatever is what the
commercials look like when I was a kid
uh anyway and when I drive it through
the mountains ah bam I nailed it [__]
nailed it
a while you [__] hit a half court
shot there is nothing that makes me
happier because then it's art science in
nature the trifecta
lay is this guy Single Ladies you got to
[__] get with this this guy's a
romantic uh hopefully one day I'll have
a couple of sports cars you know what
nothing would make me happier sir than
if that came if that came to be they
make me feel better about the fact that
I got two pickup trucks and a car uh my
car my question for you is this
how much money would you be making
yearly
should you be making yearly in relation
to the car for example if the car is a
hundred grand how much should be making
yearly to feel comfortable and deal with
unexpected expenses
finally despite the lack of world word
economy here
my brother and I are both comics and we
think you're one of the greatest of all
time you are a certified Legend look at
this and your contributions to the art
form will not be lost as you Influence
People Like Us every day all right I
wrote that final paragraph I pretended
he said that
um thank you I appreciate the kind words
um all right if you make for okay if a
car cost a hundred grand
well I remember back in the day they
used to say your rent should be no more
than two weeks pay
um
and then they kept printing a trillion
dollars every August this year they're
going to do it in June with nothing
behind it so I don't know what that is
now
but
um
I'm a [__] conservative son of a gun
here
car cost a hundred grand
and it costs five grand to do a [__]
tune-up on it I mean [__]
I would say well over a million a year
well over and I wouldn't buy the car
until I bought a house
um
so funny buy a house and then spend the
rest of your [__] life fixing every
goddamn thing that breaks on it
you know what
I I you know someone I have no [__]
idea I've never even thought about that
all I know is is like I absolutely love
machines I love cars Aviation
RVs boats I don't give a [__] what it is
if you turn it on and it goes I am
absolutely fascinated with it and I'm
thrilled for the person that owns it
people that have snowmobiles
I got a buddy of mine my old boss
I still talk to my old boss how funny is
that I had a boss like [__] 35 years
ago I talked to him probably three times
a week about sports
[Laughter]
and he keeps inviting me to go
snowmobile and I'm like I gotta get back
there I got to get back East you know
when it's [__] snowing out
um
motorcycles
I just find all of that [__]
old [__] new [__] weird [__] I like all
of it so I'm just happy that you have
the car and uh who the [__] are you as a
comedian that you can buy a hundred
thousand dollar card I don't know who
you are I would think you're making a
lot of [__] money right
um
which is another good thing I hope you
bought that car telling jokes that's
even better dude once you buy when you
can buy a car like that live in your
dream you're literally getting away with
murder
it's amazing and you know something when
you live a life like that
you're a happy guy and then you root for
people
you know
when my life wasn't going well I'd see a
guy in a Porsche you know I don't think
I I mean
I would have to look at the guy if I
looked at the guy he looked like a
douche look at this [__] douche in
his [__] poor I would say that but I
I didn't straight across I was never
straight across the board because I was
always too enamored
with the car
um so if the person was actually didn't
look like a douche then I would just be
looking at him like wow what's it like
to be you
but if they look like a douche I was
like yeah [__] that guy with this stupid
ass [__] car
um
I don't know I can just tell you I would
not buy a [__] excuse me Jesus Christ
Hiccup and a burp
um I would not buy a [__] uh hundred
thousand dollar car
before I owned a house but I'm also of
the generation that like to watch the
NBA when seven Footers battled under the
rim so I don't know what's going on I'm
also of the generation where they told
you when you're that you know you could
do a stand-up special you was the
comedian didn't decide and there was
like [__] HBO was where you wanted to
be that was it now there's like a
zillion places you go so I have no
[__] idea all I know is I'm happy
that you have that car and you're
[__] enjoying it all right that's it
that's the podcast
um go [__] yourselves and I'll check in
on you on Thursday